60 minutes plus is looking at the
continuing fallout from a dark period in
our history for decades it was legal to
send someone to prison in the state of
louisiana even if the jury was not
unanimous these so-called jim crow
juries were created after the
emancipation of slaves to make it easier
to imprison people of color louisiana
voters overturned the law three years
ago but many people incarcerated under
those juries are still fighting for a
retrial
60 minutes plus correspondent wesley
lowry spoke with 52-year-old anthony
bolt who's been in prison for decades
there are 600 men and women still
incarcerated some of us serving life
sentences without probation
parole or suspension of sentence
predicated on a law that was devised to
reinstitute slavery in the state of
louisiana in 1994 bolt was charged with
second-degree murder and second-degree
attempted murder after a shooting at a
house party left one man dead and both
bolt and another man wounded
he insists he was not the shooter but
acknowledges he had a physical
altercation with the victim that night
the following year bolt was convicted
do you remember the day that the verdict
came in oh yes like yesterday what was
that day like for you it wasn't shocking
that i was convicted
it was kind of like a
numbness and when i discovered that i
was convicted by a non-unanimous jury it
went from a numbness to a shock really
the jurors had been split with 10 voting
to convict and two voting to acquit
in nearly every other state in the
country that tally would have resulted
in a hung jury and a mistrial
instead
bolt was sentenced to life in prison
so two of the jurors voted to acquit yes
what did you make of that the idea that
two jurors said this guy's not guilty
well at the time um
to be honest i was on the impression
that you had to be convicted by
unanimous jury so you didn't even
realize this could happen no not at the
time i was young and i had never been to
trial and
how did you feel when you realized that
i just couldn't believe that i was i was
going to be sentenced to spend the rest
of my life in prison
where
two jurors found me not guilty do you
consider that an injustice of course it
is of course it's an injustice and
wesley lowry joins us now wesley doesn't
feel right and voters in louisiana
actually decided it is not right they
overturned this law three years ago what
happened
so it's a little bit complicated as you
guys noted great these laws were put in
place following emancipation because
louisiana wanted to take steps they said
this explicitly in the state legislature
to retain a system of white supremacy
keep it easier to keep locking up black
men and black women this law stated in
the books for a century right up until
just a few years ago you could be
convicted
with just nine or ten votes for
conviction so you could have two or
three jurors who said this person is not
guilty
voters in louisiana overturn the law
but that what that did was it meant that
people couldn't be convicted on split
juries moving forward it didn't do very
much for someone like anthony bolt who
had already been convicted by a split
jury the supreme court would later come
in
and kind of uphold what the louisiana
voters said they they said look it's
clearly unconstitutional this can't work
this way but even the supreme court did
not apply that ruling retroactively so
again meaning people who had already
been convicted by a split jury remained
in prison what we're seeing now is a
campaign led by formerly incarcerated
people local activists public defenders
who are fighting to try to figure out
some level of recourse for the 1600 or
so people who are currently in prison in
louisiana having been convicted by a
divided jury and so in some cases
district attorneys are reviewing their
own cases and their jurisdictions as the
case in new orleans
there's discussion in the state
legislature about passing a new law that
maybe would grant automatic retrials to
people or have the governor's office
renew it but again in the meantime we've
got sixteen hundred people who were
convicted um in a way that the u.s
supreme court in a pretty scathing
opinion
led by conservative justices like neil
gorsuch that have said look this is
clearly racist clearly unconstitutional
and yet today as we're chatting anthony
bolt is still in angola one one person
would be too many 1600 is truly a
travesty we hope there is some movement
in their cases wesley lowry thank you
very much of course thanks for having me
you can watch wes's full report right
now on 60 minutes plus it's available on
the viacom cbs streaming app paramount
plus